foreign
[Music]
look at that
[Music]
Pac-Man's a loser Pac-Man's a loser
Pac-Man's a loser
[Music]
look at that Alex Jones is lying to you
that might come as a shop
[Music]
this is
him
[Music]
four foot tank over censorship debanking
arrest tyranny look at that look at that
corporate takeover censorship debanking
arrest tyranny
[Music]
definitely take over censorship
demanding a rash tyranny
[Music]
[Music]
look at that
[Music]
people don't yell while wearing suits I
know of a guy who fits that bill of
aggressive with political will but David
packed him shall see your political
knowledge sign the foreign
[Music]
[Music]
or memberships now for the bonus show
that's best well you tell me I mean is
there a president right now I guess
um well
I'd rather not answer that how's that
congratulations
[Music]
I've been growing with one huge pepper
all summer
[Music]
my land
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
la la la la la
[Music]
la la la
I'm worried about my espresso machine
it's not a joke I'm worried about my
legs
[Music]
pillow
just exploded
felt and Dawn turned him into prison by
his pillows I'm not a lawyer the lawyers
are lawyers the lawyers are lawyers the
lawyers are lawyers get rid of the
machine I'm trying for getting rid of
the machines just pillows who did this
attack who did this Cyber attack so you
have you know the good Geeks and they
patch it up and they fix it and they put
up better protection virus protection
but here's what my attorney said he said
[Music]
um
do you frequently go to Hardee's is that
a common place you go okay that's pretty
funny
that could be your headline the machine
I said I would have passed through on
the lid to find a ride through it's
really incredible The Branding around
that I said no you're not giving my
phone I said arrest me I've done nothing
wrong he said no we're not gonna arrest
you I swear you can do anything you have
yet and you can do it you can do okay
[Music]
get rid of the machine I've tried for
getting rid of the machine I'm worried
about my pillow no no truth that's the
worst thing for you because your
cervical nerves in your neck I will send
you some big pillows I'm worried about
my legs I'm sorry about getting rid of
the machines Okay Melt them down turn
them into prison bars
pillow all right thanks Mike Take Care
thank you bye
now that we are up under our body's
regime
my bag of mangoes now costs
[Music]
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
a bag of mangoes mango art mangoes
that's it eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome everybody it is an
incredible debate night in America
tonight Ron death santis the Florida
Republican Governor against challenging
Democrat Charlie Crist it is a raucous
atmosphere as you can see in Fort Pierce
Florida where a guy with a fake new CNN
sign who looks like he painted his face
white like a mime is holding it up
Behind These broadcast anchors and as
you can see it is absolutely Bonkers
there should be an historic debate as
Jeremy Ranch says on Twitch now we are
going to go through all the setup all of
the
elements to this entire debate but one
of the things that you all know I don't
do is tell you that things are anything
other than what they are sure I would
love for Charlie Christ to be crushing
Ron DeSantis like Plato in his hands
right now
that is not what's going on
that is not what's going on and indeed
if we look at the latest polling Ron
DeSantis has opened up a 10 point lead a
10-point lead over Charlie Crist if you
look just about a month ago it was
DeSantis plus seven plus five plus four
plus three
and it is now almost exclusively
double digits
wow
particularly significant given that Ron
death santis could be the 2024
Republican Presidential nominee it seems
as though that Florida Sunshine Has
cooked the common sense out of many
Floridians brains
not everybody wants to hear it
not everybody's willing to say it but it
seems to be what happened
and uh Joseph R Rogan Jr has now started
pushing DeSantis and it's a lot of
DeSantis uh nonsense going on so it is
not looking particularly good for
Charlie Crist but we deal with it as it
comes we deal with it as it comes I want
to say thank you to Jason sickmeyer for
signing up on our website joinpakman.com
let me remind you if you want a free
membership to my website
did everybody hear that how much does it
cost it's free
what do I have to pay for it it's free
okay please no emails about how much it
costs it's free
you sign up at davidpackman.com free
membership we're just giving them away
Jason sigmeyer just bought one that
means one person gets a free membership
if you want to get on the list you don't
email me
you don't send me a telegram you don't
send me registered mail
you just go to davidpackman.com free
membership
it is free meaning you pay nothing now
as you know nothing is really free
someone else is paying
but it is free to you no emails about
the free memberships they are ignored
davidpackman.com free membership okay
very good also I want to say thank you
to punk on a bike irie man and pink and
blonde for the twitch Prime
subscriptions there's a hype train one
minute away one minute away on Twitch
I will just mention that uh and then
also a very big thank you to Paula
Gardner Paula welcome you are a
beautiful human being for signing up and
I really appreciate that now it is not
only
the Florida numbers that are looking
increasingly bad
for Democrats we talked about this on
the podcast today
including on the bonus show which I hope
you have
um Democrats are collapsing in the house
now they were never favored to win the
house but look at look at this look at
that that is just horrible Democratic
odds of winning very very bad
and even if you look in the Senate what
was once a 70 plus percent chance of
Democrats holding the Senate has
declined to basically a coin flip look
at this look at this
yes
there are horrible ignorant people
in the United States and they vote
and they vote Obama now a couple other
announcements to make
uh many of you I don't know why the
screen is black I I guess they're just
in a commercial break
yeah we'll give it a second
um many of you call in all the time
and you say David
I've got these co-workers they believe
the vaccine magnetizes your arm they be
believe antrifa did the riots or
whatever
how do I how do I talk to these people
how do I argue with these people okay
we are now working on I'm calling it a
white paper because it sounds a little
more high brow it's basically a guide
you know but I I like calling it a a
white paper
um we are working on a white paper
that will basically have
five to seven sections of how to deal
with people who believe crazy things
okay number one
employing
I call it an empathetic but employing a
Socratic method of questioning
knowing what questions to ask about how
people know what to believe all these
different it's going to be free okay
again
we we have hired a team to write and
design and lay it all out at my
direction we're just paying because I
think this is valuable and by the way if
this white paper does well we will do
more
we will do how to talk to people who
believe crazy things about abortion one
focused around medical disinformation
because there are very clear ways that
we can figure out is this medical claim
backed by evidence
all of these guides if I'm dangling but
if the first white paper does well and
by does well it just means people get it
people that it's going to be free we
will be giving it away for free do
people understand that
how much will it cost let's just see if
people are listening how much will the
white paper cost let me know in the chat
five dollars oh no
oh my God
holy [ __ ] okay now I know we're all just
kidding around in any case I just think
this is worth doing and I think it would
be good for the show to build our
reputation on the fact that we produce
these high-value pithy five page guides
to talking to people about stuff okay
it'll be a few weeks at least until it's
out but I will let you know all about it
okay
um insane things are happening I want to
say thanks to Jen here and elevated disc
golf for the twitch Prime subscriptions
um we have our coupon code today's big
voting 22 just a reminder people should
vote in the upcoming election let's go
to super chats thanks for the great
stream David I've heard multiple people
say they don't want to put their ballot
in a mailbox because they don't trust
neighbors is this a sign we are too far
gone that is a very very disturbing sign
very disturbing sign
sir the polls always tightened closer to
the election is something unusual this
year compared to others or is the media
hyping a typical Trend depends on the
race there is not one answer to that
please consider this super chat in lieu
of the free membership request form
thank you Daniel I appreciate that very
very much
um okay
I have a new song to debut for everybody
oh you know before I do that actually so
I am hold on let me see if I can pull
this up
uh
uh yeah let me do so we are in the
middle of a sort of a studio rebuild and
I tweeted about this and I didn't get
like the best responses
we're doing a studio rebuild one of the
things I need is a new desk here's my
dilemma okay right now I have
over in another area
just like my little office desk with a
different computer
and that's where I like prepare the show
and that type of thing and then I have
this desk which is the studio TM the
studio it's its own desk with its own
computer
I want to consolidate this just to have
more room and so I need a desk sturdy
enough
to mount all of my different things
big enough to have my four monitors but
also convenient enough to have both the
office and the studio now you know they
make stuff like this this is a standing
desk
L-shaped so for example I could have my
studio here on the long side
and just like my little office area on
the short side this is an idea but then
other people said you know you don't you
don't really want this because the
studio part there's no sense in moving
it up and down you're gonna have it
fixed based on your camera and all these
things that's absolutely true so one
suggestion was get the standing part for
the office piece and just have the other
part not move but then what do you do
with cables if it's all connected to the
same computer if only half of it goes up
it's sounding complicated the point is
it doesn't have to be standing but I
would love suggestions on a good desk
for streaming where I can put my
different technical elements on the desk
etc etc
I can't look at the chat and like write
down suggestions so if you have
suggestions please email info
davidpackman.com
info
davidpackman.com
and then I'll check them out all right
new song for everybody this is a really
really really good remix this is by
Chris Barrios this is really good from
my recent interview with Mike pillow
we played it in the intro this is the
official debut let's listen together
I'm worried about my espresso machine
it's not a joke it's just I'm worried
about my lathe
[Music]
um
I'm not a lawyer the lawyers are lawyers
the lawyers are lawyers the lawyers are
lawyers get rid of the machine I'm
trying for getting rid of the machines
and they patch it up and they fix it and
they put up better protection virus
protection but here's what my attorney
said she said
um
do you frequently go to Hardee's is that
a common place you go okay that's pretty
funny
that could be your headline the machine
I said to find a ride through it's
really incredible The Branding around
that she said no you're not giving my
phone I said arrest me I've done nothing
so no we're not gonna arrest you I swear
anything you happier and you can do you
can do okay
get rid of the machine I've tried from
getting rid of the machine I'm worried
about my pillow no no truth that's the
worst thing for you because your
cervical nerves in your neck I will send
you some big pillows I'm worried about
my legs
okay turn them into prison bars
all right thanks Mike Take Care thank
you bye all right so I I absolutely love
that I think that that's extraordinarily
well done really really really really
well done okay other super chats build a
desk with a butcher block and by
standing desk legs you can get a big
eight or ten foot butcher block
that's not a bad idea is it
do you connect the legs to the butcher
block or is the Butcher Block heavy
enough to just be stable
if someone can tell me exactly what to
get at Home Depot I would be open to
that that sounds interesting to me right
the Butcher Block will probably be 400
bucks but some of these desks are
insanely expensive
send me info on that I'm interested
what's your favorite track Off Taylor
Swift's new midnights album I haven't
heard a single song I Don't Know
have you looked at the desks they use at
Mar-A-Lago they can hold 11 000
documents without being all over the
floor that sounds pretty good I should
look into that
um thanks to shorty 6890
for the twitch Prime subscription you
were new subscriber number eight today
new subscriber number eight today very
very much welcome and so glad to see you
let's look at a couple other things here
here's a funny Herschel Walker clip
where he is weighing in on everybody's
favorite time of year Halloween and one
of the problems we got is guys you know
Halloween is right around the corner
that's a problem and now the people of
China and Mexico addressing fentanyl up
and look like candy so I want you to be
very Vigilant when you're taking your
kids on Halloween because there's a new
war in time and that war is China that
war is China because China don't like
yeah I don't know that I've seen any
actual evidence that there is fentanyl
or as they like to call it Fentanyl
in candy it seems sort of like one of
these things they just say and it's not
even really clear
where they got the idea I don't know I
just it just seems like fear-mongering
and by the way even if they're also I
mean many things why would drug dealers
just like give away Fentanyl
in candy
to poison kids when they could sell it
it doesn't really make sense
um and also if it was happening
it would have nothing to do with Joe
Biden they seem to always make it Joe
Biden's fault I don't know I don't
really get it uh okay super chats David
will your white paper be flushable yes
it will be a flushable PDF which is
something they've never seen before but
it would be
very very interesting
um
so you know that's that's what it is
um do we have voicemails yeah I'll I'll
play like one voicemail I don't want to
get too deep into voicemails though
4th of October and I was watching a
breakdown of Trump's insane speech and
wherever the hell it was Texas I suppose
and he was making jokes about
prisons and rapes and stuff and what I
can tell him somebody who has worked
with inmates directly is that most
happen to be right with the white ones
anyway are pretty well right-wing
Christians so that whole crowd around
him is cheering and screaming USA that's
pretty much the crowd that's in prison
so think about that one
yeah that's uh
quite a declaration quite a declaration
David I taught my three-year-old
granddaughter to respond with with the
investigation when I say we're looking
very strongly at the origin oranges
nicely done
let me see if I have that here hold on
uh oh God wait a second glitches here it
is
oh where's or oh I don't have it here
we've endorsed JP right JD Mandel I've
had more investigations and Jesse James
and Billy they could sir will you cover
the fetterman Oz debate tomorrow yes
please make a note of that tomorrow
night is the fetterman Oz debate and I
will be covering it 8 P.M Eastern it
starts I will be starting at 7 30 p.m
Eastern tomorrow night expecting it to
be a very very strong debate
thanks to McKinley as well as Beth
Graham for the twitch Prime
subscriptions folks let me invite you
now uh and if you have an objection let
me know otherwise forever hold your
peace get yourself a membership on my
website today today big voting 22 is the
discount code we primarily depend on
folks who sign up on the website we are
now developing white papers on how to
talk about politics with friends family
and co-workers and get them to think
about what they are saying and the
nonsense coming out of their mouths
all of it is funded by the membership
program I will make you a beautiful
offer you can't refuse sign up on the
website use the coupon code and I will
thank you profusely and say such great
things about you that you may not even
believe the things I say because they
will be so positive
and by the way on that note I want to
mention one other thing
it came to my attention our colleague
John told me about this
last month we had
4.3 million different people watch Clips
on our YouTube channel 4.3 million
only a third of those people
are actually subscribed
to the YouTube channel
okay only a third
if you aren't subscribed because you're
like I don't know the algorithm feeds me
the videos anyway
okay
just hit that subscribe button because
it actually is a huge algorithmic Factor
think about that 1.5 million subscribed
2.8 million not subscribed it's insanity
it's complete and utter Insanity all
right we are moments away moments away
from this debate between Ron DeSantis
and Charlie Christ
uh starting at about three minutes yes
tomorrow night fetterman versus Oz it is
happening I hope everybody will be
joining me it's going to be absolutely
fantastic let's see if we can squeeze in
uh just like one or two other voicemails
San Diego love your show I was watching
the baseball playoffs and Stephen
Miller's uh sponsored commercial which
is completely disgusting kept coming on
and I'm just thinking you know these
Baseball fans are the people that are
the middle they're The Independents they
don't pay much attention to politics
from their day-to-day life and that's
the people see I think that's a that's
not accurate just because you don't pay
attention to politics doesn't mean
you're in the middle I know tons of
people who pay no attention to politics
but they go oh yeah I'm a republican
it's like really
well who what who do you like what I
looked at officials I don't know I don't
even I don't even follow it but I'm on
the right I'm a conservative I don't
believe for a second that the people who
don't pay attention are in the middle in
fact I think a lot of the people who
don't pay attention vote for republicans
and that's a very sad thing it's really
a shame
I think is the way that I would say it
uh not good
not good at all
let's see what else I have here
uh Whitney
so I found this article about China and
I wanted to read it it says uh Russia's
Ukraine disaster exposes China's
military weakness Beijing knows its own
military has much in common with
moscow's ineffective Force wow Whitney
doing foreign policy analysis now not
something I would have necessarily
expected
sure can says there's an article from
August on the DEA website about fentanyl
looking like candy not being candy just
looking like candy interesting
I was not aware of that
might I suggest including a pacman gold
coin for YouTube subscribers that I
can't do
that I can't do
working on videos about R in German time
for Germany to join the fight our media
didn't even cover the doc's case would
you mind if I place this ad
man I don't know what compromise is
talking about but I appreciate the Super
Chat sounds interesting
agree regarding Republicans not paying
attention especially to the facts I
appreciate you agree with me
always welcome but your people are just
as welcome to disagree with me quite
frankly
um okay
wfl oh do we have to go to the other
website in order to see I think we have
to go over here
let's see here
maybe they're not streaming this here
oh they have this here as well all right
we'll just keep an eye on all this stuff
somewhere the debate is going to start
soon
and I believe we won't miss it
both of these sites seem to happen
all right very good thank you to Brandon
naput who just signed up at join at
pacman.com thank you Brandon let's go
Brandon very much appreciate that
um the debate is now it's a one-hour
debate
remember that tomorrow night the
fetterman Oz debate is an hour later
than today that one will be at 8 pm
Eastern 8 PM Eastern
Super Chat my mom and sister don't pay
attention they literally just ask us who
has policies that aligned with their
views my dad and I follow politics
closely
interesting insights I appreciate that
when is the debate now guys the debate
is now
we're just we're just monitoring
everything
it looks like it will be starting any
second
uh thanks Jeannie for the five dollar
Super Chat very much appreciate that
[Music]
Daniel Moshi love to say oh this is
something else okay so I guess we've got
to be here
all right let's get the shot properly
set up
[Music]
beautiful question the candidates will
each have one minute to respond here we
go and 30 seconds for a rebuttal that
started quick alternate who answers the
question first and at the end of the
hour each candidate will have 60 seconds
for a closing statement
you may notice at home and here in the
theater a small fan next to one of the
podiums that is there by special request
for Congressman Krist
we do ask that everyone here in the
theater remain quiet during the debate
we will have time for Applause at the
end of the night and right now as we
welcome our County really calling
attention to that huh it's state of
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis and
Congressman Charlie Crist
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
all right
we need to get going we have such a
short amount of time gentlemen welcome
we're going to begin with a series of
questions about the economy Congressman
you won the coin tossed so you will be
answering first please
it's been said that people vote with
their feet and their feet are bringing
people to the Sunshine State by the
thousands that has put unprecedented
pressure on housing it's driving rents
through the roof and forcing individuals
and families out of their homes new
housing takes years to approve and to
build and Workforce housing is needed
right now what Solutions do you propose
as Governor to manage future growth and
ensure affordable housing is available
to everyone Congressman you have one
minute to respond thank you Liz and
thank you for being here tonight I want
to thank everybody for watching this
evening I wanted to start out by saying
that you're going to see a stark
contrast in this debate in this election
it's a stark contrast between somebody
who believes in a woman's right to
choose I think that's fundamentally
important
Governor DeSantis has signed a bill that
would restrict that right even in cases
of rape or incest so get to your
question housing is an incredible issue
as well we have a housing crisis in our
state good luck buying a home good luck
renting an apartment and it's because
Governor DeSantis has taken his eye off
the ball he's focused on running for
president in 2024 and as a result we
have lost things in our state budget
specifically a Housing Trust Fund that
has hundreds of millions of dollars that
he along with the legislature have cut I
would restore it I would make sure that
we're doing everything we can to be sure
that housing is Affordable again and
along with that goes so many other
things the price of gas the price of
utilities these things are through the
roof we have inflation in Florida that's
unique to any other state and the
problem is our inflation's too high
that's time Governor you have one minute
thank you I didn't really hear a
solution there for tuning in you know
Charlie Chris has voted with Joe Biden
100 percent of the time
[Applause]
up the cost of everything that we're
doing and the fact of the matter is over
the last two years we've now have record
inflation all across this country at
40-year highs he supports Biden's energy
policies which have made gas and
utilities more expensive that is wrong
and I would also say this you mentioned
Liz that people are flocking to Florida
that would not have happened if Charlie
Chris had his way he wrote me a letter
in July of 2020 saying you need to shut
down the State of Florida he said you
need to force people to shelter in their
own homes that would have destroyed the
State of Florida that would have caused
that would have caused our tourism
industry to go into the toilet it would
have locked out millions of kids from
school I rejected Charlie Chris lockdown
letter I kept the state open and I kept
the state free and we now have the
biggest budget surplus in the history of
Florida uh we have a 2.5 percent
unemployment second lowest on record and
we just did the biggest tax cut in
Florida thank you Governor that's time
thank you very much well we're on that's
rich you're the only governor in the
history of Florida that's ever shut down
our schools you're the only governor in
the history of our businesses I never
did that as Governor you're the one
who's the shutdown guy we need to have
somebody who's at the helm that
understands it's important to listen to
science to do what's right to utilize
common sense you don't just shut down at
the outset and then when it's you know
politically convenient for you you want
to open back up the store political
points
Governor you have 30 seconds well so he
opposed having kids in school his
supporters sued me to keep the kids out
of school in 2020 and how and how
critical was that decision we just got
the nation's report card the results
from all 50 states Florida number three
in fourth grade reading and number four
in the country in fourth grade math and
if you adjust that for demographic we
are number one in the country in both
just for demographics if we let Charlie
Chris and his friends lock our kids out
of school like they did in California
and like they did in New York we did it
right in Florida we're going to move on
now our next question also on the
economy as Governor both of you called
special sessions of the legislature to
address Florida's home insurance crisis
Governor DeSantis just announced another
will be called by the end of the year
Dave in Ruskin Florida wants to know
what do you think are the best next
steps to address this crisis which seems
to overwhelm every solution we throw at
it Governor you have a minute well first
I think we have the worst inflation of
40 years it's much more expensive to
replace a roof today than just three
years ago thanks to the buying Chris
policies that unfortunately is
contributing to the increase three years
ago the number one we're number one in
the nation in litigation with respect to
homeowners insurance we have eight
percent of the police but 78 percent of
the litigation cause some policyholder
will get a twenty thousand dollar
settlement and the lawyer will get four
hundred thousand dollars so we call the
special session we address part of that
we also created a reinsurance backstop
it's serving us well now that hurricane
Ian hit and we created a program where
Floridians can get grants to make
improvements of their homes and then
lower rates I think what we need to do
we need to build off what we did with
the reinsurance because that's a big
issue and we have to address the rising
costs of litigation it's not about
lining the pockets of billboard lawyers
it's about having a competitive market
where people have a shot to make ends
meet congressman
the real problem is that according to
Forbes Magazine Florida is the most
expensive state in the country to live
in more than California more than New
York and why is that the case because
you've taken Your Eye Off the Ball as I
said before look at utility rates in the
State of Florida as since you've been
Governor every utility rate increase has
been granted for Florida Power and Light
Duke power Tico you name them they've
all gone up and up and up when I was
governor they went down property
insurance
property insurance under you has doubled
in the State of Florida doubled Ron
that's not good for the people of this
state and it's been exacerbated by this
horrible hurricane hurricane we just
came through gas prices are up as well
under your lack of leadership you
slipped in something to drop the price
of gas but only in October right before
the run-up to the election that's so
political it's it's disgusting we need
to have a governor who will do what's
right for the people of Florida all the
time all year long not just when it's
right before a re-election Governor but
they're both coming out swinging very
very solid so far
the wire Fuel and natural gas prices up
because of the bidencrest energy
policies they're Waging War on American
Energy they are not producing what we
need to do they're begging Maduro and
OPEC for more oil that's why your costs
are going up there but Charlie Chris
plan for homeowners insurance is to dump
chase the private insurers out dump
millions of Floridians on citizens
property it's under capitalized here's
why that matters for you citizens has
mandatory assessment Authority so there
could be a storm that hits Tampa Bay
maybe you're renting a place in Miami
with a massive obsess your homeowners
insurance your Auto's insurance and your
renters insurance his plan would end up
capsizing the State of Florida not a
real storm Congressman you have 30
seconds thank you Liz I appreciate your
courtesy
um you know I think it's incredible that
we hear this out of Ronda santis he's
talking about our economies talking
about property insurance and everybody
watching tonight knows that your
property insurance is up under him
that's the problem
he could have addressed it in the
regular session he didn't he could have
addressed it in his first special
session he didn't he's now calling a
third special session I don't think the
third time's going to be the charm
because his focus is not on Florida it's
not on you you deserve a governor who
has your back I always did and I always
will
ing to stop right now and ask that our
audience please stop we're not going to
get through all the questions and we
have a lot of ground to cover so please
please that needs to be the end of the
Applause we'll have time for Applause at
the end
our next question as communities rebuild
after Hurricane Ian a story of
Destruction and Recovery we cover again
and again do you believe it's time for
new regulations restrictions or limits
on where and how we build along the
coast being on the water is a defining
part of the Florida lifestyle but these
homes and businesses are regularly
subject to devastating losses which then
cost all of us billions does something
need to change congressman
you know uh hurricane Ian was a disaster
storm a nightmare frankly uh we had uh
you know the structure go up for all of
the buildings in Florida right after
Hurricane Andrew years ago and thank God
that happened and in this part of the
state where the storm hit right after
Hurricane Charlie even more so so I
think we've addressed that what needs to
be addressed is how we treat a storm
before it makes landfall and
unfortunately Governor stance has failed
on this what happened is this storm was
approaching Florida one of the biggest
storms in the history of our state the
most deadly storm in the history modern
history of Florida and what was governor
DeSantis doing the Friday night before
it made landfall he went to a football
game he was a fall AWOL for almost 24
hours didn't encourage Lee County to
evacuate and as a result a hundred
people lose their lives that's not a
good record and that's not good
leadership and Florida deserves better
we have to be prepared when the storms
are coming in he had access to all the
modern technology you could have all the
modern radar available and it still
failed to have them evacue Congressman
that's unbelievable look I I'm proud
that we had 42 000 linemen stage ready
to go unprecedented array of First
Responders we were able to get in in
record time effectuate thousands of
rescues get the power back on for
millions of people in record time and
when the bridges got wiped out in Pine
Island and in Sanibel people thought
those islands were going to be severed
from the mainland for six months to a
year we did the Pine Island restoration
in three days and we did the Sanibel
Causeway Restoration in two weeks now
those islands have the ability to
recover and Charlie Crist is sitting
there you know what he was doing during
this he was in hiding out in Puerto Rico
he wasn't helping his community here and
then when he got back what did he do
and then when he got back what did he do
his campaign was soliciting campaign
contributions from Storm victims that is
unacceptable and that's not what a
leader would do in a time of Despair
Congressman you have 30 seconds Governor
that's not true and you know it let's
face what the facts are in this
situation so you know whether it comes
to covet or comes to the hurricane Ron
ignored science
he doesn't think that they know what's
right to it to apply to and he thinks he
knows better than everybody look at any
issue that we're facing in the State of
Florida he thinks he's the only one that
has the right answer whether it's you
surfing your local school board whether
it's doing anything else in education
Banning books for example I mean it's
unbelievable what has happened and so
you have to apply science and do what's
right for the people and protect them
Governor yeah and I reject uh my
opponent's attempt to politicize this
because these local communities did
mobilize and if you looked at that track
everyone was focusing on Tampa Bay the
Monday night before the storm we woke up
Tuesday Morning the models had shifted
into Sarasota all the folks in Southwest
Florida were activated Lee County did
Issue evacuation couldn't he have just
drawn on the mark on the map with a
sharpie and changed the direction of the
hurricane Lord so people were following
that very intently those folks did a
good job you know the governor our
message was listen to your locals it's
ultimately a local decision they do the
shelters but I stand by every every one
of our local counties they stood up and
worked hard and they made the best
decisions they took with the information
that they had
our final question on the economy John
in Gainesville asked what are your plans
to reduce the effects of inflation on
Floridians if the federal government
cannot come up with a viable solution
nice fair question well we know that
these are the effects of the Biden crisp
policies the worst inflation in 40 years
and Charlie Chris votes with Biden 100
of the time and he says that Biden the
best president he's ever seen so he's
locked together with these policies that
have hurt so many people throughout our
state and our country here's what we're
gonna do one we have the fifth lowest
gas prices in the country right now
because we did do a gas tax holiday
we're proud of that what we're going to
do for Floridians who commute we're
going to reduce Tolls by 50 percent
Statewide for all commuters in the State
of Florida we are going to make all baby
items diapers cribs wipes you name it
tax-free permanently in the State of
Florida so you can raise kids and get by
you know we have a five and a four and a
two-year-old our two oldest are out of
diapers my wife asked me why didn't you
propose that your first year in office
well you live and you learn and we're
also going to say that pet food is going
to be tax-free in the State of Florida
so this is going to be the largest tax
relief plan in the history of the State
of Florida you're able to do that when
you have a strong economy in the largest
budget surplus in history which we have
right now
Congressman you have one minute
well that's interesting I would agree
with your wife you should have done that
the first year you were in office I mean
aren't you supposed to be helping us all
four years instead of just the last year
and Ron Ron you talk about Joe Biden a
lot I understand you think you're going
to be running against them I can see how
you might get confused but you're
running for governor you're running for
governor and I have a question for you
you're running for governor why don't
you look in the eyes of the people of
the State of Florida and say to them if
you're re-elected you will serve a full
four-year term as Governor yes or no
yes or no Ron will you serve a full
four-year term if you're re-elected
governor of Florida
it's not a tough question
it's a fair question he won't tell you
we did not agree on the candidates
asking each other my science Governor
it's your turn well listen I know that
Charlie is interested in talking about
2024 and Joe Biden but I just want to
make things very very clear the only
worn out old donkey I'm looking to put
out the pasture is Charlie Chris oh God
oh it just got very ugly
not an answer
you want to talk talk about standing
standards uh when Charlie Chris was
governor he ran saying he would not
raise taxes he became governor and he
signed off on the largest increase in
taxes and fees in the history of the
State of Florida we just enacted the
largest decrease in taxes in the history
of Florida thank you Governor
Congressman you have 30 seconds yeah
well Ron we know you love to bully
people and the little name calling you
just exchanged I can take it but you
shouldn't do it when children are stand
behind you at a press conference and
they're wearing a mask
but apparently that's your nature and
that's too bad so what we need to do on
the economy is make sure that we're
focused on Florida you know he keeps
talking about the Biden Administration
this the Biden Administration that this
is the DeSantis Administration and under
the DeSantis Administration the middle
class is getting crunched in Florida you
can't get an apartment you can't afford
a house you can't pay your property
insurance because he's taken his eye off
the ball over and over and thank you
congressman
we are now going to move on to another
topic it would be great if the
scientists answered whether he'd commit
to serving four years the pandemic and
remote learning expose parents to what
was going on in America's classrooms
like never before disputes over masks
and reopening schools had Parents across
Florida demanding more say in their
children's education part of your
response governor was to sign the
parental rights and Education Act which
you Congressman called a quote heinous
piece of legislation
Governor DeSantis the parental rights
and Education Act and the stop woke act
are centerpieces of your agenda for
Florida schools why and Congressman do
you believe it's important to educate
students in kindergarten through third
grade about sexual orientation and
gender identity Congressman you have 60
seconds what I think is important is to
educate children on science math and
history and true history and facts these
questions are insanely biased Florida 9
000 teachers and staff have left Florida
because of the way he is treated public
schools in our state and it's wrong
we are the third largest state in
America and his administration is paying
our teachers 48th out of 50 states
that's embarrassing we can and we should
and we need to do better than that we
need to have a focus on education and
not politicize and make political war
zones out of our schools we need to
support our schools support our teachers
have our parents involved that's
absolutely essential and that's what we
need to get back to is Basics instead of
having all these cultural and political
Wars that Ron loves to do as I said
because he wants to run for president
and he's out of state raising all this
money all the time Governor you have 60
seconds well um you know I would say
when you oppose the parents rights and
education bill which prevents
six seven eight-year-olds from having
sexuality gender ideology injected in
their curriculum you are the one that's
waging the culture War I'm simply
defending parents and students because
it's inappropriate to have that in
elementary school it's inappropriate to
tell a sixth grade a six-year-old that
they were born in the wrong body it's
inappropriate to tell an eight-year-old
that they may have been born a girl but
maybe they're really a boy that's wrong
we need to do the basics we need to
teach them to read write add and
subtract and if we do that we'll
continue to lead in fourth grade reading
and fourth grade math like we did in
today's nape results which is a great
Testament to having open schools and a
lot of hard-working folks in our school
system I also signed I'm the I'm the
father of a five-year-old daughter and a
two-year-old daughter as well as a
four-year-old son but my daughters are
very athletic and we sign legislation to
protect the right of women athletes that
you should not have someone competing on
the men's team for three years and then
switch to the women's team Charlie Chris
deposed that bill he said he would to
vetoed it I'm going to protect women's
sports in the state of Florida
[Applause]
go again Ron it's all about culture wars
it's all about dividing us I'm a uniter
I think we need to be to be giving our
state a chance to unite again you love
dividing our state you know whether it's
blacks against whites whether it's gay
against straight whether it's young
versus old you're making it harder for
people to vote in our state you know we
just started
early polling today early voting rather
today and he made it harder to mail in
ballots I have a 90 year old father an
88 year old mother they love to exercise
vote by mail he's made it harder along
with the Florida legislature that's
anti-democracy governor
I think denying girls and women athletes
the right to compete fairly I think
that's divisive I think it's divisive to
rip opportunities away from our girls in
the State of Florida and you want to
talk about divisive the day after
Charlie Chris won his primary he said
anyone that supports the governor you
have Hate in Your Heart and I don't want
your vote well think what that means I'm
endorsed by every police group in the
State of Florida I'm endorsed by the
firefighters I'm endorsed by the
truckers the nurse and necess Retail
Federation Farm Bureau the whole
cross-section of the State of Florida is
backing me they do not have hate in
their hearts because they reject Charlie
Chris they want to keep Florida going
and they want to keep Florida free
our next question is also on education
critical race theory has ignited
controversy in school districts around
the country here in Florida it is now
against the law to give lessons which
might cause a student quote
psychological distress because of
actions in which the person played no
part committed in the past by other
members of the same race color national
origin or sex what do you believe is the
best way to address issues of race in
our history and in Modern Life in the
public school setting Governor well
Florida Statutes require teaching all of
American History including slavery civil
rights segregation it's important to
vets taught but what I think is not good
is to scapegoat students based on skin
color it's not good to distort American
history by saying that the American
Revolution was fought to defend slavery
which is not true I think we should have
a history like Abraham Lincoln believed
in our founding uh like Frederick
Douglass these are great Eternal
principles we've got a great
Constitution and people have used those
principles to make great progress over
the course of our country's history I'm
proud of our history I don't want to
teach kids to hate our country I don't
want to teach kids to hate each other
and the way to stop discrimination on
the basis of race is to stop
discriminating on the basis of race
the people calling out racism are the
real racists
you know he talks about not not teaching
about the history of our country that
might offend some people in our schools
we ought to teach facts in our schools
in our schools there's an old expression
Ron those who don't know history may be
condemned to repeat it usually people
use that in reference to the Holocaust
it could just as easily be referenced to
slavery in our country it happened it's
a fact we shouldn't have a whitewash
approach to educating our children
that's not right how are they going to
do well in life if they don't even know
our own history and we're not going to
teach people to hate each other in our
schools I don't know where you get that
idea I don't have hate in my heart and I
don't think we need to be doing that in
our schools wow why you think that's
happening right now is beyond me we need
to get back on track we need to apply
Common Sense we need to do what's right
and you're taking away from all these
other issues because you don't want to
talk about taking away a woman's right
to choose
[Applause]
and you've even signed a bill that would
take away their right in cases of rape
and incest it's unconsciousness
you're gonna have to leave it right
there Governor you have 30 seconds yeah
so it actually if you look around the
country they do have programs
unfortunately well they will take a
student look at their race say okay
you're white you're an oppressor if
you're black you're oppressed and think
about what that does to a six or seven
year old kid that's wrong you're seeing
that you have people that are teaching
and actually his running mate has said
this in the past that teaching the
United States was built on Stolen land
that is inappropriate for our schools
it's not true uh is it is that not true
accurate history and we're going to make
sure that we honor those who have
sacrificed so that we can be free
Congress in 30 seconds
30 seconds well listen here he goes
again I mean he keeps going back to this
stuff these outrageous radical kind of
comments that have nothing to do with
reality he says they're teaching this in
other schools in other states this is
Florida
you're the governor of Florida right now
you won't even say if you want to be the
governor of Florida after this election
but you are right now and you need to be
focused on what's happening in our
schools our schools are doing a decent
job and they're not teaching hate
they're teaching Reading Writing and
arithmetic they're doing it with good
teachers but you don't respect them and
that's why they're fleeing our schools
we need a governor who cares about
education
Chris is starting to get under
desantis's skin without teachers and
districts up and down the state are
struggling to fill open jobs even though
the National Education Association
reports Florida now ranks 15th in
starting teacher pay
Governor you have proposed making it
easier for veterans and First Responders
to join the ranks of public school
teachers but some argue your policies
which we have just discussed are a
barrier to new Educators Congressman you
believe the solution is declaring a
public emergency and increasing spending
for health care and other benefits in a
system that already makes up a
significant chunk of the state budget is
money the answer Congressman money does
help
you know if you you invest in what you
care about and you prioritize by how you
spend your money this Governor as I said
before is spending for our teachers
they're 48 out of 50 states in America
we're the third largest state in America
he's got a budget surplus why can't you
treat teachers better than that that
doesn't make sense to me
you invest in what's important uh in
other areas of our state you make sure
that we have infrastructure that's why a
member of Congress I voted for the
infrastructure they got the Sanibel
Bridge built back up as quickly that you
took credit for but it's important to
invest in things that matter to the
people of our state like actually
regulating our utility rates and you're
not like actually Bringing Down the
price of property insurance and you're
not like actually making sure that our
taxes are lower not higher you raise
them a billion dollars on every consumer
in the state you did that you raised the
highest taxes ever now
Governor you have 67 well I think a
secure pay is really important and when
Charlie Chris was governor he did
nothing about it for four years in fact
he cut education 300 million dollars
what have I done we've done the largest
increase in teacher compensation in the
history of the State of Florida as you
mentioned Liz we now rank much higher
with average minimum salary because we
focused on that because we knew that was
important to recruit good teachers so
we've raised the average minimum salary
by over 20 percent we're now number one
in the Southeast and I created with the
legislature a categorical budget item
number one in the southeast look at the
other states in the Southeast and their
education records you know his running
mate is a teachers union boss she makes
almost two hundred thousand dollars a
year the teachers down in Miami don't
make that so I don't want the money I
mean every superintendent that makes
that as well what does that mean it's a
teacher so we are going to do a billion
dollar categorical in next year's budget
we've made tremendous progress and we're
going to continue to do it because we
know how important it is
30 seconds
Ron when I was governor we paid our
teachers more per dollar than you are
and you have a surplus I governed to
when we had a Great Recession and we did
it because we prioritized it it was the
right thing to do that's how you need to
lead you need to lead by uniting people
not dividing them he talks about
dividing us all night long it's what he
does it's who you are it's what he's
about you deserve a better governor who
cares about women and your freedom your
freedom and your right to choose
and so we're going to continue to do
more with the teachers but I think this
is also important we're talking about
schools uh I oppose allowing school
districts to force students to get the
covid shot Charlie Chris wants to force
students to get the kovid shot uh we
passed a bill to prevent that he opposed
the bill when we did it I think this is
a parent's decision I think it's wrong
to force this on these kids and as long
as I'm Governor as parents you're going
to have the ability to make that
decision we are not going to subcontract
out your parental rights uh to Charlie
and especially with his buddies we're
going to move on now please no we
already had your 30 seconds
I'm sorry Congressman Public Health
which has been at the Forefront of
public policy debate for the past couple
of years perhaps never more so than
after the Supreme Court overturned Roe v
Wade right now a legal challenge to
Florida's 15-week abortion ban passed by
the legislature and signed by Governor
DeSantis it's making its way through the
courts the Florida Supreme Court which
will ultimately decide on this issue has
previously found the state
Constitution's privacy Clause applies to
abortion access
this question comes from Wayne in Stuart
in your opinion after what week of
pregnancy should abortion be banned
governor
well I was thinking back in the
aftermath of this to a poor woman over
40 years ago in Jamaica and she found
herself pregnant didn't think there'd be
much opportunity to have a child was
urged to to abort the baby went to get
the abortion and um you know for for
whatever reason and maybe we can't
explain that didn't end up happening and
she ended up having the baby and I think
about that because a few months ago I
appointed her daughter to be the first
Jamaican American Justice in the history
of the Florida Supreme Court are these
stories were better when everybody
counts I understand not everyone's going
to be born in perfect circumstances but
I would like to see everybody have a
shot I'm proud of the 15 weeks that we
did I know Charlie Chris opposes that
even though the baby is fully formed has
a heartbeat can feel pain and can suck
their thumb he also supports set
selective abortions which is used to
discriminate against little girls he
supports dismemberment abortions where
they literally volunteer the baby limb
from him and he supports taxpayer
funding of abortion all the way up until
the moment of birth and that is wrong
Congressman you have 60 seconds it's not
the truth and you know it you know it he
wouldn't answer your question do you
want to ban abortion completely he never
got to it he talked about Jamaica I
don't want to be an abortion I want to
make sure we keep a woman's right to
choose available to the women of the
State of Florida and I want to make sure
that we don't have a governor in the
future who wouldn't even allow
exceptions for rape or incest we just
found out recently about a case of a
middle school girl near Jacksonville who
was a victim of incest became
impregnated because of the bill you
signed Governor she had to go two to
three states in order to take care of
this issue that's not compassionate
leadership that's not doing the right
thing that's not even having a heart
that's callous it's barbaric and it's
wrong and Florida deserves better and if
you want better I hope you vote like
that
Charlie Chris has not only supported
abortion up until the moment of birth he
even voted against the infant born alive
act which would have had medical care
for an infant that survives an abortion
attempt and is born alive he's also
somebody uh something of a little bit of
a chameleon I mean he used to support a
federal constitutional amendment that
outlawed all abortion regardless of any
type of exceptions now he's taken the
Other Extreme position the question is
is this an honest change of heart or is
this a guy that's going to shift with
whatever win he needs to to try to keep
his political career alive I think we
all know the answer to that question has
DeSantis answered a single question
Ron again that's not true and you know
it
you know I watched you debate four years
ago and I remember your opponent said
that you know in the last debate I guess
he got two instead of the one we're
getting
he said Ron lied 21 times and when you
did it again in his second debate he
goes well there's number 22.
you are so compelled to be
disenfranchised from the truth as much
as you are maybe it's because you don't
want to talk about your record you don't
want to talk about how you've made
Florida unaffordable for most of our
citizens you don't want to talk about a
woman's right to choose and these other
things that are so important to Florida
that's fine thank you
moving on to our next public health
question the coronavirus continues to be
a significant concern a pandemic was not
something any of us were prepared for
there was no Playbook no list of time
tested strategies to stop because Trump
threw it in the toilet and dangerous
virus by the summer of 2020 Florida was
slowly reopening under Governor DeSantis
while Democratic members of the state's
Congressional Delegation including
Congressman Chris were calling for new
stay-at-home orders and a Statewide mask
mandate looking back more than two years
later are you satisfied with your
approach to the covet response
congressman
yeah I'm satisfied with my Approach I
would have listened to scientists unlike
the governor
you know he wants it wasn't the question
for DeSantis listen we reopened that you
can keep things reopened but you got to
do it with an eye tour of how care
providers tell you
not being arrogant so arrogant that you
won't listen to their advice about when
masks are appropriate and later on when
they probably are not like now we don't
need them now but you'll take a common
sense approach and to do what's right
Ron I wouldn't pat yourself on the back
too much about your response to covet
we've lost 82 000 of our fellow
Floridians
and when you look at the Thanksgiving
table one of those empty seats is
probably one of those people for many
families watching tonight
and if we had only had the standard of
other states in the United States 40 000
of those people would still be alive
enough to fill Tropicana stadium in St
Petersburg that's tragic
[Applause]
in July of 2020 and if that had happened
in this state it would have destroyed
the State of Florida our hospitality and
tourism industry which is Thrive would
have gone into disrepair it would have
thrown millions of Floridians into
turmoil and I can tell you as Charlie
Chris and his friends in Congress were
urging you to be locked down I lifted
you up I protected your rights I made
sure you could earn a living I made sure
you could operate your businesses and I
work like heck to make sure we had all
our kids in school in person Governor
five days a week
Congress in 30 seconds
and we had one of the highest death
rates in America Ron and over 6 million
of our fellow Floridians have gotten
coveted under your leadership now that's
not something to be boastful and proud
about I'm pro-business I want to make
sure we keep our businesses open I'm not
the governor who attacked Walt Disney
World because they danger expressive
point of view
I'm not the governor who attacked the
cruise industry because they just wanted
to make sure that their customers
weren't sick before they got on the boat
that's you you're the most anti-business
Governor I've ever seen
except for all the businesses that are
moving down here and leading the nation
in net in migration and I'm proud you
know we said seniors first we work with
nursing homes we work with testing with
seniors we did monoclonal antibodies and
the result is 38 other states had higher
covered mortality rates for senior
citizens than we did in Florida I mean
they lied about the numbers so who knows
what they had focus on the vulnerable
population but make sure you're not
locking down the rest of the people
we've thrived as a result that would not
have happened if Charlie Chris had got
his way and locked down the State of
Florida in July of 2020. thank you
governor
across the country and here in Florida
lawmakers are divided on the issue of
gender transitions for minors the
Florida Department of Health has held
firm that there are risks associated
with imagine this even being like a top
issue therapies for children despite
pushback from the federal government and
other states where do you stand on
minors undergoing so-called gender
affirming medical procedures and
therapies Governor well so-called is
important because when they say gender
affirming care they mean giving puberty
blockers to teenage girls and teenage
boys they mean doing double mastectomies
on young girls they mean chemically
castrating young boys that is wrong we
are not going to allow that to happen in
the State of Florida a lot of kids go
through a lot of different things a lot
of the dysphoria resolves Itself by the
time they become adults and we have a
number of people that have spoken out in
favor of what we're doing to say you
should not mutilate Miners and they went
through this when they were miners now
Tulsi is one of them and other countries
in Europe that went down this road have
now backtracked and so we're doing the
right thing it's inappropriate to be
doing basically what's genital
mutilation
this reminds me of your position on a
woman's right to choose you think you
know better than any physician or any
doctor or any woman in a position to
make decisions about their own personal
health you want to be the judge you want
to decide about what people should do
with their own physical being with the
betterment of their health with whether
or not they want to make sure that they
can practice their right to choose as a
woman that's just not right I don't
believe in that I believe that we need
to do unto others as we would have done
unto us it's called the Golden Rule and
Ron
if you ever knew the Golden Rule clearly
you have forgotten it you don't have the
temperament to be kind and decent to
other people who don't look like you who
don't act like you
and don't contribute to you
but we're all children of God
and that doesn't mean that you're the
one who's supposed to judge about what
other people are supposed to do
particularly women with their body
Governor announced 13 and 14 and 15 year
old kids they are not in a position to
know whether they can undergo a radical
procedure that physically Alters their
body if you're a 15 year old you can't
go get a tattoo in the State of Florida
yet we're saying you could get a double
mastectomy of course not it is
inappropriate to do this for minors and
in Florida why does he say mastectomy in
here on this one
again you know this is a difficult for
miners I mean you should just be honest
with it
for anybody and you know he talks about
it like it's fun it's not these are
difficult issues and they deserve mature
leadership and you just need to have a
governor who understands that a woman
has the right to choose that you need to
have somebody who understands
and respects that decision I was raised
with three sisters
I'm an only son I learned as a very
young boy to respect women
and it's important to respect others
when that's time and it just doesn't
sound to me like Governor DeSantis wants
to do that to respect some other
family's decision about what they want
for their children we're going to leave
it there thank you
moving on now to another topic gentlemen
illegal immigration continues to make
headlines from our Southern border to
the shores of our state Governor your
Administration recently used State funds
to transport migrants from Texas to
Martha's Vineyard why
and do you believe that was an effective
use of taxpayer money Congressman you
called the flights inhumane do you
believe Florida should be a sanctuary
state congressman
I thought what the governor did was a
horrible political stunt
um you know we have an immigration
problem we have a problem at the border
we need to secure the Border I agree
with all of that but it doesn't mean
that you use Florida taxpayers dollars
to Charter two jets go to Texas DeSantis
will say it was like Federal coveted
money right up to the northern part of
our country and and one of them's a
one-year-old baby
another is a pregnant woman you're
willing to use people like that in this
case they were Hispanics Venezuelan in
particular
and have them as props for your
political gain that's not the way to
change policy you can change policy and
do what's right to secure the porter by
having comprehensive immigration reform
that's what I voted for in Congress when
you were in Congress you wouldn't do it
because you want to keep this issue
alive you want to have it as a wedge
issue and you want to pull political
stunts like you did with the taxpayers
dollars of the people of Florida that's
not what it's for that's not what you
should have done it isn't funny it's not
right and you were inhumane and how you
treated these people that's time
congressman well you say you're for the
secure border but this is all happening
under divided Administration and the
policies that Charlie Chris supports uh
we've had millions and millions of
people pour in across illegally we've
had record numbers of fentanyl come in
we now see it ravaging our communities
like never before I didn't hear uh
people like Charlie's stressing outrage
about that we've had criminal aliens
come in the country we just had a
sheriff's deputy from Pinellas County
killed by a twice deported illegal alien
who came across the border illegally six
months ago I didn't hear any of the
outrage about that it's only when they
go to DC New York or of course Martha's
Vineyard then all of a sudden this is
you know why because we have Elites in
this country that want to impose
policies on you but they don't want to
have to suffer the same consequences
that you may have to in your community
what we did it's sad that it comes to
this but what we did put this issue
front and center I think we need to
reinstitute remain in Mexico and I think
we need to secure the Border because the
fentanyl is absolute really out of
control
if you want to secure the Border you
ought to support policies that actually
will secure the Border like
comprehensive immigration reform when
you were in Congress you wouldn't do it
because you like having it as an issue
for political scoring in points that you
want to have for a future campaign and
let me remind the viewers he wouldn't
even answer you if he would stay for
years if you re-elect him as your
Governor you're running for governor
you're asking them to vote for you for
governor at a minimum you ought to be
able to tell them if you get reelected
you'll serve as governor Ron Governor so
we had the border that was in much
better shape in January of 2021 the
Biden Administration reversed almost
every policy that was Chris should keep
hammering on that that's why we have the
problem it's not from some Phantom piece
of legislation and you know I hear
Charlie Chris talking about some of this
other stuff you know he is a congressman
made 174 thousand dollars a year you
know how many days he showed up to work
in Washington D.C this year 14 days
imagine that deal for you you show up 14
days and you make over 100 Grand that's
the type of effort this guy puts into
actually doing his job I mean how many
session days were there
I do want to remind both of you that
your campaigns agreed that candidates
would not ask each other questions just
wanted to remind you
drug smuggling is another consequence
why and an insecure border and according
to the cdc's most recent data Florida is
only second to California in the annual
number of Overdose deaths what will you
do as governor over the next four years
to protect Floridians and their families
from drugs addiction and the crime that
comes with it Governor first let me tell
you what we have done and we've done
half a million doses of Narcan to First
Responders which have saved a lot of
lives we also created a core program
coordinated opioids recovery and
basically we're trying to get people who
are addicted to have stabilization in
their life we patterned it after a
program in Palm Beach we now have 12 of
these addiction stabilization centers
around the State of Florida and then I
sign legislation raising the penalties
for people who are trafficking Fentanyl
and Fentanyl analogs if you're
trafficking that garbage that poison you
are killing what about digital Fentanyl
and it treats you like the murderer that
you are
Congressman
what we're talking about enforcing our
laws making sure that we have leaders
that understand that these laws are on
the books for a good reason
so what you need to do is have somebody
as an attorney general I actually served
as attorney general the top cop of
Florida and I understood in that role I
understood in that role how important it
was to enforce our laws and we did it
day in and day out it's important to
make sure that not only with the drug
problem we're dealing with but also all
the laws in crime crime is up under
Governor DeSantis crime was down when I
was your Governor because we enforce the
laws in nature Floridians were safe
that's the kind of leadership that we
have to have it's Common Sense
leadership stop the flow of drugs I
already told you we need to secure the
Border I support that he said that I
don't but I do and I think it's really
important that we have common sense
applied all these issues enforce the
laws keep our state safe keep our
schools safe he won't even effectuate a
ban on assault weapons to keep our kids
safe in school that's wrong I think it's
right we ought to do it
well this is an important issue because
uh Charlie Chris has endorsed the idea
of quote reallocating funding away from
the police I guess to give to social
workers but if someone's robbing your
house you don't want a social worker
coming up to help you you need the
police and so that's why all these
police groups are endorsing me and they
have said that Charlie crisp crime
policies are very dangerous he used to
be tough on crime when six political
parties ago but now he's admitted that
he has softened up on crime but we've
seen what's happened in all crop places
all across the country people are moving
to Florida because we're a much safer
State Than The Californians and the New
Yorks of the world
Well Ron if that's the case how come
crime is up under your four years as our
governor and and you talk you think you
allege that I want to defund police as a
member of Congress I voted for another
200 billion dollars to go to law
enforcement in our country to fund the
police once again he misrepresents the
facts it's a shame that he does it but
we have to get back to basics folks this
is our state this is our Florida we need
to have a governor who will bring us
together not divide us like he's doing
all night
do we have time for one more question
we do
continuing now on the topic of Public
Safety earlier this month Nicholas Cruz
who confessed to murdering 17 students
and staff at Marjory Stoneham Douglas
High School on February 14 2018 was
sentenced to life in prison you have
both said that he should have received
the death penalty but legal Scholars and
at least one juror blamed Florida law
for sparing his life I'm against it if
elected will you take action to change
existing law why or why not Congressman
what I would do in this case listen
these are not easy decisions uh I served
as Governor I signed death warrants
Governor DeSantis has as well it's not a
fun day but it's important thing to do
as I told you earlier you need to carry
out the law as it applies to this
particular case this is one thing we
actually agree on I believe that that
young man should have gotten the death
penalty for killing 17 innocent students
in our schools it was absolutely
abhorrent and you have to do what's
right and it's a tough thing sometimes
but whatever it takes to make sure that
we can enforce those laws that say there
are consequences to your actions we need
to be able to enforce them and get it
done right governor
I think he deserved the ultimate
punishment when you murder in Cold Blood
17 innocent people there's no other
punishment that meets the gravity of
that crime and to have one juror hold
out on that was a travesty so yes I'm
going to ask the Florida legislature to
amend that statute so that one juror
doesn't have veto power over appropriate
punishment but I'll tell you this when
that happened I wasn't Governor yet it
was the year before but I became friends
with a lot of the families people like
Andy Pollock Ryan Petty no one was being
held accountable for anything that was
going on there I came into office my
first week we suspended the sheriff of
Broward County for the ineptitude that
was displayed we called the special
grand jury Statewide grand jury to look
into the failures of the school district
and other school security failures that
report came back we've instituted great
reforms we've done a court three
quarters of a billion dollars for school
security and I was able to remove
suspend four school board members that
the grand jury had said were derelict in
the performance we brought
accountability for those families when
no one else would Congressman you have
the floor 30 seconds those weren't the
only people he removed from office we
have a state attorney in Tampa Bay named
Andrew Warren that he of his own
volition decided to kick out of office
and suspend because he actually spoke
about what he felt about an issue that
used to be called freedom of speech in
this country and Governor I know you
went to Harvard Law School but you need
to study the Constitution again when you
start removing people from public office
that's the job of the people he was
twice elected State Attorney in Tampa
Bay did a great job and because he
voiced something that disagreed with you
you decided to suspend them that's not
good leadership Congressman Governor you
have 30 seconds yeah look I think that
it's a very important issue for our
country prosecutors aren't Above the Law
they don't have the right to veto duly
enacted statutes I know Charlie Chris
supports prosecutors like LA and
Manhattan that are basically ignoring
the law and crime is spiking in those
areas I disagree with that I think in
Florida you can can't be a lawn to
yourself as a prosecutor duly enacted
statutes must be enforced and we will be
much safer as a result of that so I
acted appropriately and I would do it
again
that is all the time we have for
questions at this time gentlemen you
each have one minute for a closing
statement the coin toss determined that
the governor will go last so please
begin Congressman wow I want to thank
Floridians for watching tonight I love
Florida I love her with all my heart I
want them unite her I want to bring this
state back together not have a divider
as a governor I want women to have the
right to choose and make their own
decisions about your body
especially in cases of rape or incest I
want to make Florida more affordable
again when I was governor I lowered your
property insurance when I was governor I
lowered your property taxes when I was
governor I made sure that we had an
affordable economy even in a recession
he's raised all these things he's also
raised your taxes he won't even tell you
if he'll serve four years if you
re-elect them I mean come on you deserve
better than that Florida deserves better
than that thank you very much
well said
governor
Governor you have your closing statement
Now 60 seconds well thank you we have
accomplished an awful lot over these
four years we have the largest budget
surplus in history we have a 2.5
unemployment second lowest on record and
we just delivered the biggest tax relief
in the history of the state we've
expanded school choice we've protected
parents rights and we've done the
largest increase in teacher pay in
Florida history and even though it had
years of neglect we made historic
restoration for our Everglades and
improvements to our water quality
because water is the foundation of not
just our economy but our way of life and
then when a once in a century pandemic
hit I led based on facts not based on
fear I lifted you up while some like
Charlie Chris wanted to lock you down I
took a lot of flack in the process but
through it all I was always more
concerned about protecting your job than
I was about saving my own I took the
arrows so you wouldn't have to uh we
have we will continue to fight the good
fight we will continue to run the race
we will continue to keep the faith we've
accomplished an awful lot but we've only
begun to fight God bless you and I ask
for your vote on November 8th
our Media Partners our audience
thanks for watching
well with the couple minute late start
and the three-minute early end
essentially a 54-minute debate during
which we didn't learn a lot but what a
debate trading blows
but I have to say I I do I do think here
that a Charlie Crist made a very good
case
unfortunately DeSantis is winning by 10
and it simply may not be enough to close
the gap tomorrow night ladies and
gentlemen tomorrow night Oz V fetterman
one of the most anticipated debates of
the Season we will be here live
subscribe free on YouTube folks be one
of the 1.5
12868 million
that makes sense I think so uh make sure
you're following on Twitch make sure
you've liked on Facebook so that you'll
be notified tomorrow night Mehmet Oz
against John fetterman questions about
everything from fetterman and his closed
captioning device to Everything Under
the Sun and whether Oz uh will sort of
like have a freak out as summer
predicting he will do
uh I want to say thank you to S Prez for
continuing to lead in gifted twitch
subscriptions putting us today at 100
out of 100 with a massive dump of 77
subscriptions gifted on Twitch truly an
historic day we will see everybody here
tomorrow and it will really really be
something else let's raid our friend
Eric Rosen it's been a while since we
raided him on Twitch I think it's going
to be a really really great time come
along with me for the raid if you are
watching on Twitch and we will be back
tomorrow for folks it's going to be an
incredible day see you then
foreign